From the time I and my beloved went to a party
His old lover was present at the ceremony
He turned to me and asked me, "Did I know you?"
I answered him with all literature
Why do not I expect my father to meet her?
Ok
Because this subject was strange to me
I mean, I do not meet my father Mo Moalishani immature
I wish
But why not meet someone you grew up with
This is all my father I think about
Is it wrong that I am not friendly and I am surrounded by a strange attitude?
Then fat we speak and absorbed ..
Are you a friend of all your former granaries?
I mean. Why Ante?
Here. No. I'm Mani authenticated by one of them. no one.
Absolutely
Why do not you hate them?
Not what I hate them. But I hope the first thing we separate disappear from existence
I mean, they die
They shall be born from the foundation
Ok this can be childlike
But if we broke up !! I do not want to see you again
I do not want to know about you Shi
Perhaps this is because all my failures were bad
I do not once get a mature separation for what the parties are
I love your person, but I think we are compatible
Oh, I agree, I expect you are wonderful, but what we are attracted to
I love to be friends
But it will take time for Anasaki
Sure, so am I.
But, when I'm ready, I hope to be friends
No
If the break was classical music
My break is loud music
رااااار !!
Tbe leave me !!?
I did not ever run a girlfriend with a former lover
Not once
The fact that my lover is a constant friend with his granules
Great food. honesty.
WOW Explain to me your relationship?
Such as when you see a new color, or you discover a new species
So the idea that you got a friend was your lover ..
Is a new concept for me
My God!
It is impossible to get.
But, maybe I'm Mani's friend with my lover
Because I was not his first friend
All relationships start with romance
It was a solid foundation for friendship
I do not have time and prepared one of my friends
And then we return friends
But, who knows?
I mean, are you a friend with a former lover?
Or are you childlike like me and wish they
They were not born from the foundation.
I am an Akana, and stay great
Advertising